In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 6 on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Thomas, on the 6th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle Thomas.
The Holy Apostle Thomas, also called Dittamus, was born in Judea.
His parents were poor but they passed on to him a great love for the Law of Moses.
When he was still young, he drew apart from the noisy games of his companions to devote
himself to reading and meditating upon the scriptures.
His knowledge of God's word and will disposed conscience enabled him without hesitation
to recognize Christ as the Messiah, spoken of by the prophets, and to follow him as
soon as he called him.
He left his boat and his nets and became one of the twelve.
He was persecuted, excluded and stoned by the Jews, yet followed the Savior everywhere
with such burning zeal that when Christ took the road for Jerusalem to offer himself
for those who were going to kill him.
Thomas said to the other disciples, let us also go that we may die with him.
When the Savior of the world had overcome death by rising from the tomb, he appeared to his
disciples who were assembled with the doors shut for fear of the Jews.
He showed them the marks of his passion upon his body and the disciples were filled with joy.
God so provided that Thomas was not then with them, and when the others told him that
they had seen the Lord risen from the dead, he was unwilling to believe them.
In his great patience and forbearance, the Lord appeared again to his disciples a week
later, and asked Thomas to certify that he was well and truly risen from the dead in
the flesh.
He told him to put his finger into the holes in his hands, left by the nails, and to thrust
his hand into his side pierced by the spear.
In admonishing Thomas for his lack of faith, the Savior showed that we too are called upon
to thrust our hands into his side, not physically, but spiritually, to quench our thirst there
at the wellspring of grace.
Thomas was with the other apostles when on the day of Pentecost the Holy Spirit came down
upon their heads in the form of tongues of fire.
He was filled like the rest with power from on high for the proclamation of the world's
salvation, and when the Holy Apostles went their separate ways, it fell to Thomas to bring
the glad tidings to the distant lands of the Meads and Parthians, Iran, and as far as India.
At that time there was in Jerusalem a man called Ambanas sent by an Indian king to find
an architect with skill enough to build him a palace that should surpass in beauty and
adornment any constructed by previous master builders.
Made known to Thomas that this was the providential means for him to fulfill his mission, so he
made out to Ambanas that he was a slave, expert in the builder's art.
They took ship for India, therefore, and arrived at the court of King Gundafar.
The king was enraptured by the plan of the magnificent palace that Thomas laid before
him, and left him with a large sum of money for building it, before leaving for a three-year
tour of some distant provinces.
As soon as he had charge of these riches, Thomas did not delay in distributing them to
the countless poor, starving Fulcum the king and his nobles had taken no care for at all.
As well as relieving the poor, the apostle worked miracles and preached the gospel to
such good effect that a great many pagans were brought to the faith.
When the king sent to know how the building works were getting on, Thomas asked him for more
gold on the pretext of finishing the roof.
The king was delighted and immediately sent what he asked for, and it never entered his
head that Thomas was giving it away as soon as he received it.
All the more terrible was his wrath then, when he found out that he had been tricked, and
that the saint had given all his money to the poor.
Thomas was shot up in a deep pit, and the king had the most dreadful torments in store
for him.
But that very night, his brother, who was grievously sick, had a vision of an angel who
carried him away and showed him a magnificent palace in the everlasting kingdom of the righteous.
The angel said to him, Behold, the palace prepared for your brother, built for him by the
apostle Thomas.
When he came to himself, he described all he had seen to the king, and how much more
beautiful than any earthly dwelling was the palace Thomas had built for him in heaven.
Completely overwhelmed, the king repented, released the apostle, and asked for baptism with
his brother.
St. Thomas then left for another kingdom, where barbarity and godlessness held sway with
yet more violence.
But in the power of the Holy Spirit, he succeeded in converting Tersia, the king's wife, her son
Azzanas and her two daughters, Megzonia and Marza.
He baptized them and taught them how to follow the way of perfection in Askees and Chastity.
This seemed a peculiar and senseless way of life to the lustful king, and it threw him
into a rage.
He had St. Thomas seized and ordered five soldiers to spear him through on a mountain, outside
the city, so it was that the apostle departed to rejoice forever with the Lord.
He is venerated as the founder of the church in India.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.